seed oils cause sunburns
since you're an educated person I assume
you know the answer to that
yeah
you got this wrong because you're gonna
have to drink and you have to drink a
lot really yeah why what I don't know
anything about seed oils and this was
almost a racist question because I don't
get sunburned so I this is like so I
don't I don't know anything about the
oils you're right I'm like obviously
it's not true because I've definitely
eaten seed oils and I've never gotten
sunburned for black so I'm going to do a
little Common Sense here see if this
can't be causing wow you you black
people in my teen years for some reason
I started sunburning wow and I thought
what now in retrospect I realized I was
consuming a lot of seed oils and then
sweet little Elisa who follows all the
hippie stuff that you follow Mac you
gotta stop
it's not gonna cook with it whatever
sorry Bradley reducing I was like this
is some hippie dippy mountains I don't
get sunburns anymore